in the last video we worked through
essentially the probability distribution
for this random variable defined as the
number of free throws you make when
taking six free throws assuming you have
a 70 free throw percentage and i
suggested that hey why don't you
visualize this draw the you know graph
this probability distribution this
binomial probability distribution and
what i thought about i said well you
know i i too would enjoy graphing it and
we might as well do it together because
whenever you graph these things it makes
it very visual and kind of the shape of
a binomial distribution like this so
let's let's let's do that so let me
maybe move over to the right a little
bit i really just need to be able to
keep track of
these things right over here
so
let me draw some lines so let me
if i were to just
draw one line there
and then another line
here
and then we have the different
percentages
so let's do that
see the highest one is a little over 30
32 percent so maybe we'll go as high as
40 percent here
40
percent
and then this would be
20 percent twenty but that looks about
halfway twenty percent
this would be ten percent
ten
percent and this would be thirty percent
thirty percent
and then in this axis let's do the
different
values that the random variable could
take on so the random variable taking on
taking on the value 0
the random variable taking on the value
1.
0
1
the random variable taking on 2
2
we're almost there
let's see 3
and then
four
four
and then five
five
and then finally six taking x equals six
and then six and now let's just graph
all of these so this first one
0.1 well that's barely going to register
on this graph right here so i'll just
kind of just give it a little bit of a
showing right over there actually let me
do it in that green color
so
let me
make sure so in that green color
you're going to have just a little bit
of a showing
one as well is kind of barely a showing
so you know it shows up a little bit
more so let me draw it
like that
that is one percent
right over there now two is six percent
which on this scale is going to be about
it's about that high
so we draw it like that
so that is two
so that is six
six percent right there x equaling three
eighteen and a half percent shot of that
happening
so eighteen and a half
it gets uh so right about it's a
hand-drawn
it's a hand-drawn chart so or histogram
so you have to bear with me
so it's roughly
there
and then
4
4
was 32.4
so that is up here
so 32.4
which is right
looks like that
so let me shade that in
point four percent
and then five was thirty point three
percent
so thirty point three percent and a
slightly lower just like that
and it looks
look like this thirty
three percent and finally six is eleven
point eight percent
eleven point eight percent so really
this whole video was just an exercise in
in making a histogram but it's useful
because to actually visualize to
actually visualize what the distribution
looks like and what's really interesting
is to think about well what how does
this change as you change as you change
the free throw percentage or as you
change the number of shots you take how
does this change this binomial
distribution and you can do that on a
spreadsheet and actually see how that
all how that all works out